in this lesson we'll be discussing the
vidiq reaction this reaction produces
alkenes from carbonyl compounds and this
type of compound which is called a
phosphonium illud before we go any
further we need to talk a little bit
more about the nature of this compound
phosphorus is neutral when it has three
or five bonds and here we have a bond to
three phenyl rings so these are just
benzene rings hanging off of this and
then we have two bonds to a carbon so
we're at five bonds and phosphorus is
neutral in this resonance form here
we're double bonded to a carbon so
carbon has one two three bonds and an
implied hydrogen so four bonds and
everything looks neutral in this form
but we can draw a resonance structure
where we push electrons onto the carbon
atom and produce this charge separated
form here I've abbreviated the
triphenylphosphine piece but now we can
count phosphorus still has three phenyl
groups on it three benzene rings and one
bond now in this resonance form coming
to the carbon so it now has four bonds
one less than it would want to have when
neutral the five bonds and so phosphorus
is positive in this resonance form and
since we push these electrons on two
carbon carbon has a negative charge and
this form will give a lot of insight
into the reactivity when we look at the
mechanism now you may not be all that
familiar with phosphorus compounds yet
so let's just take a look at how we can
make these conveniently we can start
from familiar alkyl halides so I'm using
the bromide here but the chloride
anything really with a leaving group
that can undergo an sn2 reaction is
going to be a good candidate for this
starting point now we can treat this
with neutral triphenylphosphine
triphenylphosphine attacks at this
carbon here and in an sn2 reaction
displaces this bromine now we're very
close to making our illud however this
carbon is not yet an anion well now
having this positively charged
phosphorus adjacent to this carbon makes
these protons quite acidic we have a
strong inductive effect pulling
electrons toward this positive charge in
this bond this makes these hydrogen's
much more acidic and so we treat this
with a relative
strong base perhaps sodium tert-butoxide
this deprotonation generates our illud
which we can represent with this charge
separated form or as this neutral
resonance form this reacts with carbonyl
compounds producing alkenes since we've
already shown the arrow pushing for this
sn2 reaction let's start here sodium can
be regarded as a spectator ion so we
only need to show the tert butoxide
portion to show the deprotonation of
this acidic proton now I'm going to
leave the illud in this charge separated
form to show you the rationale for why
it attacks the carbonyl the way it does
we'll align this so that the oxygen and
phosphorus are close to each other lined
up in this way this is because of the
dipole in a carbonyl compound we have
this great dipole here pulling electron
density toward the oxygen and away from
the carbon the oxygen is Delta minus the
carbon is Delta plus we can even draw a
charge separated resonance form for this
as well but drawing our compound in this
way aligns the negative charge near the
Delta positive carbon and now we can
show our electrons attacking the
carbonyl carbon pushing the electrons up
onto oxygen this attack step gives this
I want to point out even though this
mechanism looks really new because you
have elements that maybe you haven't
seen before this attack is similar to a
grignard attacking a carbonyl so we just
have this negative carbon attacking at
the carbonyl carbon and pushing the
electrons up now we have something kind
of unique but if we think about this we
just have a negative here and a positive
here there's an electrostatic attraction
and if oxygen makes two bonds if it
shares the electrons
it'll be neutral and if phosphorous
accepts a pair of electrons and makes
five bonds it will be neutral so now we
can show the electrons from the oxygen
attacking at phosphorus this is going to
make a four membered ring and this form
boring intermediate is called an oxy
phosphate ain the next step is going to
give our alkene directly and so we can
draw two arrows within this ring
breaking the ring to form our alkene and
the product that I haven't drawn up here
which is going to be triphenylphosphine
oxide so we can show our arrow pushing
like this and arrive at our final
products of the reaction now although
this step the fragmentation of this ring
here might be really new to you I want
to encourage you to think about the
steps that you do know and apply
concepts from things that you've seen
before here we have deprotonation of an
acidic proton driven by an inductive
effect of a positive charge right next
door here we have carbonyl attack by a
negative carbon like a grignard then we
have this snapping down because we have
a positive and negative charge that can
neutralize themselves so this is really
the only new step that you'll need to
learn here but as long as you keep in
mind what the final product is you
should be able to draw those two arrows
there are important stereochemical
considerations in the vinegar reaction
as well we first show this reaction with
a ketone and this is symmetrically
substituted on both sides so it doesn't
matter if we draw the alkene going this
way or this way it's the same product
but what if we have an aldehyde here
instead now since we only have one group
on the phosphonium illud and one group
on the aldehyde these need to be either
on the same side of the alkene Z or they
need to produce the e alkene and be on
opposite sides the major product of this
vid acree action is the z alkene
now this illud is called an unstabilized
illud and I'll show you why in just a
second that will produce the Z alkene as
the major product but there are certain
substrates that actually favored the e
isomer in a vit agree action let's look
at an example the mechanism and see why
there differ
if we treat this alpha halo ketone with
triphenylphosphine the sn2 reaction will
proceed very smoothly these are great
substrates for sn2 reactions
now we'll deprotonate to make our illud
and now of course we can draw this push
our electrons in to make the neutral
form of our phosphonium illud but we
should notice something else about this
anion here
it's basically an enolate in this case
it's alpha to a carbonyl which can
stabilize this by resonance so our arrow
pushing looks like this we get this
additional resonance form and we'll find
that whenever we have an anti on
stabilizing group like this adjacent to
the carb anion of the illud we're
actually going to favor the e isomers of
these alkenes now let's take this
stabilized illud and react it with this
compound and i am going to show you the
whole mechanism because i want to show
you an alternative way that you may see
it written
we'll use this resonance form because
it's the most convenient and we'll line
this up in the same way put the oxygen
near the phosphorous atom now these
steps can be abbreviated into one step
so in some representations you may not
see the beta Ain intermediate we can do
this by drawing two arrows here instead
of one so instead of showing our
intermediate with the negative charge on
oxygen we're gonna skip straight to the
oxy phosphate Ain now we can show the
oxy phosphate Ain breaking apart so when
predicting the major product of the vit
agree action we need to look at the
phosphonium illud that's form this one
has no additional resonance except for
the resonance that represents this as
the neutral form or the charge separated
form this here has actually three
resonance forms we could push this way
to show the neutral form but we can also
push in the other direction toward this
anion stabilising group
now the reason for this difference is
not completely understood however it of
course has to do with molecular orbital
theory because of the way the molecular
orbitals are interacting it is
reasonable to assume in this
unstabilized illud that these two groups
will actually approach perpendicular to
each other and in that transition state
if we position the large groups further
away from each other that will predict
the Z outcome of this product
but that's a little bit beyond the scope
of this video for today but through this
video I hope you're able to see when an
illa diz unstabilized or stabilized and
be able to predict whether the Z or a
alkene will be the major product of your
reaction KP here if you learn something
give me a thumbs up on the way out and
for more chemistry subscribe to my
channel